My advice to young chefs from the age of 16 to sort of 29, 30 is:...
...14 years of a sponge, you're absorbing knowledge.
Don't take a job for the sake of money.
Don't worry about earning 500 pounds a month or year, more, somewhere else.
Go and get knowledge.
'Cause that becomes a bigger passport for everything.
The money will come once you've mastered your craft and you've become incredibly talented.
Work for big chefs and find a different level of comfort.
When things get too comfortable,...
...when you're still living with your parents and you still got your first job and...
...you don't wanna move out because everything is too comfortable, get out.
Put yourself in a strange situation in the middle of Barcelona.
Put yourself in the middle of Paris.
Put yourself in the middle of Belgium and see what's available.
And it's amazing how much confidence it gives you and more importantly,...
...it's great to eat and travel at the same time.
Fantastic.